this program is brought to you by
Teachers College Columbia University
please visit us online at iTunes TC
Columbia their homes i urgently involves
questions of gender and this is I wanted
touch on one aspect of this most
intensively that my colleagues and I've
been working on in the last few years
and that is the question of health mr.
bridges to the poorest people on the
planet and specifically the challenge of
addressing health conditions and the
ongoing health crisis in sub-saharan
Africa it raises all of the issues of
course around is couch what does so in a
very dramatic as acidic context because
Africa is still burdened by a level of
disease and
massive death from disease unlike any
other part of the world and it's our
hypothesis that this can be alleviated
dramatically if we put our minds and our
hearts to it and we're already finding
some important results that are huge
positive and discernible results and I
want to share those with you and also
share with you the way you think about
this topic in the specific approach that
we've adopted so you'll forgive me for
not talking about lots of other parts of
this challenge I'll focus in on the
crisis in sub-saharan Africa as as the
central challenge of course we're
motivated by the children and the fact
that Africa loses four million or so
children under the 85 every year which
is a shocking an avoidable tragedy
because almost all of the desk of young
children our avoidable at low costs
using proven standard young preventive
and curative approaches and so the
challenge is to understand why is that
these known methods of saving life and
avoiding death are not undertaken and
what can be done of and essentially
the core of all of this is extreme
poverty and so the question is how to
save lives and sail up basic health
systems and other aspects of basic life
support and be a sneeze in a very
impoverished setting so okay mmm oh yeah
sure okay thank you any kind of approach
to this challenge of health disparities
needs a rigorous side notice we're
dealing with people and were motivated
by our hearts but our heads have to lead
the way to understand systematically
what it is that we're confronting when
we see akali such as an under-five
mortality rate of 204,000 created where
every thousand live births 200 children
will die before their fifth birthday
that's the kind of grim reality that
still plays much of something are in
Africa many of these rural areas we have
to understand that whenever I think
about health disparities and I say when
it systematically there are at least
three kinds of conditions that one needs
to understand the first are those
conditions relating to poverty because
without question health outcomes and the
ability to intervene are fundamentally
shaped by socioeconomic conditions and I
would say more specifically by economic
poverty determines the nature of one
physical environment whether you're
drinking safe drinking water or drinking
water out of a shallow well that can
kill you whether you
breathing indoor particulates from a
threesome so which can cause acute lower
respiratory infection and death has done
for hundreds of thousands of young
children whether you're protected or
exposed to malaria carrying mosquitoes
and so forth those are all like
environmental conditions that are
strongly related to poverty but of
course also related to poverty is the
question of whether there's a clinic in
the community how far it is whether you
can reach it whether there's a way to
get emergency transport whether there's
a communication system whether there
will be a nurse or a doctor there
whether there will be medicines there
whether basic preventive zar available
so poverty is for me the first of these
major determinants of health disparities
second is explosion so we know that even
in countries like ours which on average
are rich not quite as rich as we were a
couple months ago and richer than will
be tomorrow unfortunately but still a
rich country we have I'd say more than
just pockets of poverty we have whole
region's of poverty and whole
communities in poverty you wouldn't know
it by the way from our political
rhetoric training because the word
poverty doesn't show up anymore in
politics but it's interesting I was not
happy about it that in all of our
presidential debates and vice
presidential debate of worth poverty or
poor did not get raised once either a
question or an answer even today when I
will not even when David Brooks in the
New York Times wrote about how Obama
administration officials responded to
one of his earlier columns he said that
the officials were steadfast in their
determination to help the middle class
that's our rhetoric and our politics
right now we don't have more people
we only have a middle class you can
understand why that is because that's
where the median voter is so called at
but it's dreadful because we've got a
poor class and we should face up to it
and we don't take the social
responsibilities we also have people
that are excluded systematically from
access to normal parts of our society so
exclusion by gender by ethnic minorities
of course by indigenous populations not
just ours in the United States but every
single part of the world has found a way
to abuse its indigenous populations it's
the most shocking thing actually it's
just about the most systematic pattern i
know of societal dynamics if you got
there first you're going to be pretty
bloody I now something there's something
that provokes a massive attack on those
who have the original claim and who
therefore had to be pushed aside by the
newcomers in every society so indigenous
populations invariably our poor more
fluted push to more marginal light
conditions and that brings out the third
aspect of health disparities and that's
physical geography there are parts of
the world that are simply less healthy
political and many tropical environments
are absolutely by nature of the apology
more burdened by infectious diseases
especially vector-borne diseases in z's
like malaria is a temperature regulated
disease if the temperature is below 65
degrees fahrenheit or about 18 degrees
centigrade you don't get malaria
Bob you do so even in the cases of rich
countries like ours where there was some
molarity transmission historically it
was easier to control if we have weaker
whereas the tropical countries its
year-round and the burden is
intrinsically much higher similarly
places with the deficient and
unpredictable rainfall tend to be poor
face less productive agriculture more
propensity to drought and so forth so
geography plays a very important role
very often geography ethnicity and
poverty all intersect you find very for
people of excluded groups living in
marginal environments now why is that
typically it's not because that's their
native place but because that's where
they've been pushed to so sometimes we
don't recognize it that a group life on
the side we're not in the drylands of
northern tank originally they've been
pushed and many forest people have been
pushed to very difficult places because
as ethnic minorities they were literally
cleared away from more productive land
and push the more fragile environments
so these three interacting regions for
health disparities can apply and the
main two points I want to make our that
in any condition that you're addressing
of health disparities you need first a
differential diagnosis you need to make
a serious contact specific assessment
what is it that you're seeing ideology
leave it outside the door you better
understand rigorously what it is you're
seeing is it about poverty is it about
social
illusion is it about geography what kind
of combination because the rigorous
analysis is the only way you can
understand practically what to do then
typically and this is what I'll suggest
in the African context for we're working
once you have that kind of situation
analysis it's never complete you always
have to change that change your mind as
you learn then you can design a set of
interventions that are appropriate they
may be social they may political they
may be in the health sector they may be
in the environmental serum but you need
to have a set of interventions that is
based on the diagnosis that you've made
of the context and then understand how
that can be implemented so specific
things to look for the African context
tropical ecology unsafe water indoor air
pollution massive nutritional
deficiencies that goes with poverty
poverty goes with low productive farming
low productive farming goes with
marginal areas it's all interconnected
you have to tease apart these different
components but throughout the poorest
countries nutritional deficiencies
whether total caloric intake or protein
intake or specific micronutrients like
zinc and iron vitamin A and vitamin D or
omega-3 fatty acids are crucially
missing from diet and they are huge
determinants of health outcomes of
course then there's the question of
access are there health services
preventive curative health services also
family planning and contraception is
vital for health courts especially for
women's health and
itself and many poor parts of the world
do not have access to contraception and
we just added eight years where our
government did just about everything it
could to make sure that continued that
lack of access I mean and so this is a
major issue not only of choice and end
life plan but a physical health so
poverty and social explosion are
certainly the main underlying causes of
these conditions though they mix the
ecology gender ethnic exclusion often
and the economic factors directly well
that's a big slide but I'm going to
leave it with you for people that want
to have a look so you don't have to read
it Scrabble the bank notes that if
you're interested ten years ago I shared
a commission for the world health
organization called the Commission on
macroeconomics and help and the idea was
to take a look at the health conditions
in the poorest countries and ask what
could be done about it and the since I'm
an economist I spent a lot of time
following the money on this I wanted to
understand how the poverty works in
producing the bad health and how more
money mainly I argued or heavily from
rich countries could help to alleviate
these health conditions and we issued a
report that pointed out that at a very
small cost with proper science based
interventions to control malaria or to
vaccinate children or to address
nutritional deficiencies or to control
other parasitic diseases or to have
antibiotics available or to have oral
rehydration therapy available they have
community
workers a local clinic in other words
the system of health delivery for a very
low cost specifically one-tenth of one
percent of the income of the rich
countries devoted to enabling the poor
countries to sail up the interventions
that could make a difference it would be
possible to save about eight million
lives per year the number one tenth of
one percent turns out to be about 35
billion dollars a year it's roughly what
Wall Street used to take home and
bonuses each year now after they lost a
trillion dollars I trillion trillion for
us they only took home 80 billion in
bonuses last year but the point I'm
making is that the amounts that would be
needed to change life fundamentally to
save lives five millions every year is
tiny it's tiny compared to every number
stated every day about to bail out of
this or the bail out of that but we
don't do it because we do bail out banks
when we don't fail out dying for people
we don't do it yet well at least that
approach did get some traction there
were some powerful friends of it like
Bill Gates and so a period of sailing up
began and I made a list of some of the
things that I've been involved in and
that the world has taken on in the last
nine years since that commission report
part of the sailing up of access to
essential health services there's
something called the Global Alliance for
vaccines and immunizations the
millennium development goals of course
in the year 2000 of which men about
child health maternal health hunger and
disease control are directly about
health all of them
one way or another about hell but
several de millennium development goals
are specifically about health of poor
people thank the Gates Foundation
introduced so-called public-private
partnerships for new drug development in
cases were we need a new drug new
vaccine new diagnostic for some of these
killer diseases that there were many
initiatives on a TB and malaria at the
beginning of this decade just to give
you a sense of true health disparity the
world of course was engulfed in the AIDS
pandemic it still is but at that time in
two thousand there wasn't one person in
Africa a continent already with more
than 20 million infected people there
was one human being on antiretroviral
therapy supported by an official
institution because the world was
letting millions of people die every
year that's the kind of world we have
which we need to spend our time time
change and then came with Kofi Annan's
leadership with the leadership of dr.
gro harlem brundtland who is director
general world health organization at the
time with the continuing leadership of
un secretary-general ban ki-moon and
others a series of initiatives to do
something about that and especially to
get care as well as preventive services
to people who need it similarly with
malaria and with TV each of them a mass
killer ace killing 2 to 3 million per
year TV 2 million per year malaria
between one and two million per year and
as a 2000 very little was being done now
something more is being done and I'll
come back to that in a moment other
diseases were being addressed over a
longer period of time such as measles
polio and so called any ease call which
is a category called neglected being
neglected tropical diseases those are
like worm infections shift Sosa mieses
African river blindness game terrible
debilitating diseases of which there are
now some programs to address and this is
one of the areas where President Jimmy
Carter has played a personal leadership
role for a quarter century the beginning
of attempt at least to look at
non-communicable diseases like
hypertension which you find in the
poorest areas in the poorest villages
almost never diagnosed and then people
have a stroke or cardiovascular disease
as a result of undiagnosed hypertension
continuing for a long time our project
here at Columbia University is called
millennium villages project and I'll
talk about that in just a moment that's
our attempt to take the lessons of all
of these initiatives and apply them
specifically under the glia work of this
university in partnership with local
villages in Africa to prove what can be
accomplished and the results are quite
dramatic and many other advances that
are coming so one good piece of news is
that the graph turned off starting in
two thousand I know every bit of that
graph turning off is there lots of stars
from fights over that but that's to try
to get age program started Global Fund
to fight AIDS TB malaria the Global
Alliance for vaccines and immunization
other initiatives so aid started to turn
up and that made it possible to start to
prove what can be done
you're working in a low-income setting
there was the void of financial
resources people so impoverished that
they couldn't do anything their
government so impoverished that they are
going to do anything and then some
resource lone stars and the theory that
we / pounded in the Commission on
macroeconomics and health is that the
resource flow that is the money would go
a long way towards improving health
outcomes and I think that that theory is
being demonstrated and it can be
demonstrating even more we argue that
that curve should go up to 35 without
the timing was 27 billion dollars a year
now with the current prices and dollar
and for the year two thousand nine or
2010 it should be about 35 billion
dollars a year we're only one third of
the way there we used to be one tenth of
the way there so there's a little bit of
progress not enough but at least wink
one can start to demonstrate what
happens so what do you do I argue that
we need a science-based public health
strategy I like public health because I
regard as one of the great problem
solving disciplines all public health
means of course is that you're thinking
about health at a population sale not an
individual clinical treatment but at the
sale of the whole community or the whole
population and what do you do in a
public health approach in a good one
it's these steps first epidemiology you
have to know what is the disease burden
that you're addressing if one wants to
understand health disparities I'm
putting in you know not there are paint
many aspects of health good mental
health and social health I'm really
talking mostly about specific
disease burden though conditions of
depression and mental help are
absolutely among those but first is the
epidemiology to make a serious
assessment of what are the challenges
the ones confronting if children are
dying in large numbers wide and
therefore what are the kinds of
interventions that are needed then
second which I just said once you know
the epidemiology then you have to design
the what to do and I'm using the term
interventions for that that could be
very specific medical procedures it
could be specific public health
preventive procedures or it could be
something that's a little bit more
holistic and not so specific or it could
be completely outside of the narrow
public health domain it might be the
water system needs prepare have a beef
well or pipe water as a solution to
massive diarrheal disease that third is
systems design typically if you address
the ebony now do you find out that there
are modern conditions that are in play
they're interacting and you need a
systems approach multi-dimensional
different connected pieces within the
health system outside and then within
the health system a different division
of labor between doctors nurses
community health workers mothers looking
and fathers looking after their children
community empowerment community
awareness you need a systems approach
there is no magic bullet that eliminates
health disparities so one needs a broad
based systems approach then for a lot of
this especially when we're considering
control of these diarrheal disease
rested for you
he's malnourished malaria unsafe child
birth mother's dying in childbirth
neonates meaning an infant before 28
grew up to 28 days after birth died in
that extraordinarily vulnerable first
four weeks you need management it's one
thing to understand the conditions band
understand what might be done about them
the under than to understand how to do
them in the system's approach and then
to actually do them and sometimes we're
not well enough trained in management as
we need to be all the ideas can be there
but if you can't implement it it also
doesn't count and one of the biggest
things missing in a low-income setting
management capacity I've been trying to
manage it for quite a few years now we
have to manage our own life when we do
it in managing an institute or a payroll
that's also pretty tough probably not as
hard as the first but still is pretty
tough and managing a system financing
human resources monitoring evaluation
delivery logistics patient engagement
community empowerment it's not an easy
process and management skills I think
are critical so I talked about
investment planning and management
training community empowerment oversight
monitoring evaluation feedback financing
in the end someone's gotta pay for this
that's absolutely critical that's why
they let economist play in this game can
somebody's got to talk about the money
in yet and it's not a lot of money but
it's more money than poor people have
and that's the
this problem that I'm the positive side
these are solvable problems because they
don't cost a fortune to south on the
other hand the tragedy is that people
who have nothing can't even afford a
little bit and so children die because
they don't have 80 cents for a medicine
that's the world we live in it's hard
for us sometimes to imagine what it
means to have nothing but there are lots
of people who have nothing no cash
income for example human beings
desperate to stay alive desperate to
keep their children alive and we need a
system that can accommodate that and
they can't be charged when they come to
the clinic they won't come to the clinic
that will be the end these are kinds of
problems we have in our own country
obviously as well you see them starkly
in a in an impoverished village and then
finally at the end of any list always
has to be feedback meaning you have to
observe how you're doing and then make
adjustments and if you aren't doing a
monitoring and evaluation in real time
not to write your son but to know what's
happening you won't get it right so what
we're doing is not a controlled
experiment where we're trying something
for three years and we're measuring and
we're trying to design a system together
with the community and that means lots
of iterations along the way home you
can't have community house workers doing
this you can't assume that we need to
have a different approach for the third
thing so you need lots of feedback
constantly learning from the process
that you're engaged in so very quickly
up very quickly let me seek about each
of these components then open it up for
for some discussion in the epidemiology
it's now standard in public health to
identify three broad categories
disease the first hour trilogy
infectious diseases nutrition related
diseases and unsafe tile work both for
the mother and the input so that's all
category one category two are the
so-called non-communicable diseases
cardiovascular disease cancer diabetes
and so forth category three are all the
violence related diseases but it could
be deliberate violence suicide accidents
trauma and the first part of
epidemiology is to separate in a
community what do you find and if you
look at the next slide this is a
worldwide have to disaggregate these
categories across different regions of
the world I won't go into the details
now you can have a look I this is called
disability adjusted life years as the
measurement of how many years of life
are lost in the population controlling
for population size based on these
different diseases and we're at the top
the high-income countries we have the
lowest amount of disease per person
Africa is at the bottom you see it's got
a uniquely high burden of disease but if
you look at why these color codes are
different at the top of the bottom it is
all these three first category first
three blocks of the table and what are
those three those are the category one
conditions there's the infection this is
AIDS actually
this is other infections and nutritional
I'm sorry this is other infection and
parasitic and this is nutrition and
childbirth to the odd way to break it
down by the way so but I grabbed it from
a book so this is the extraordinary
burden in Africa we're facing three main
conditions infection now nourishment or
specifically under urgent and unsafe
childbirth that tells you not
necessarily the social we can out of
context or specifically the geographical
context but it does tell you what the
real cause of death and morbidity is and
therefore something about what kind of
strategy and systems one neat okay and
this is a UNICEF chart worldwide this is
global about causes of death with
children under five just to illustrate
as you can see the giant share caused by
neonatal deaths why you very young
children die in the first 28 days
obviously strong nearly precarious
moment of life but if the child worth is
in a hut if the children are kept warm
if the mother is not informed about what
a safe breast feeding practices if the
bilko cord is cut with the dirty blade
or rum with dirt as cultural practice in
some places if the child's not kept warm
if there's complications and there's no
incubator so you're
about clinical challenges and so forth
you got neonatal death pneumonia comes
from many kinds of infection including
the indoor air pollution diarrheal
disease of course from waterborne
malaria which is a much higher burden in
Africa is mosquito transmitted tropical
disease and so forth so this is also
consistent with what we saw on the
preceding ground where African that can
be fired just above it with South Asia
India Pakistan Bangladesh Nepal Sri
Lanka which is the second big area of
large burden of disease per capita ok
I'm going to move fast you can go next
so intervention strategies there's
something very specific about this
challenge not only are the disease
conditions specific but the poverty is
pervasive so one has to think about ways
to address these conditions in
impoverished setting can't be too fast
there's not going to be big hospitals
around in the rural areas they're not
going to be lots of doctors and nurses
one has to think about how to address
these conditions in a way that is
feasible I'm not saying within the
absolutely constricted resources locally
available because the whole theme is
we're going to add in resources from
outside but still to do it in a highly
cost-efficient manner because the
resources are that are available are
some stairs the world's resources are
not so stairs it's the resources
available to poor people which are so
scarce I just want to make clear the
distinction not that we couldn't do a
lot lot more we choose not
we have to understand what can be done
what is the basic package that can be
put in place and a few I think a few
guidelines that are very helpful first
it is to deploy scalable interventions
this can't be again relying on very
fancy cat stands and dialysis machines
and MRIs and so forth this has to be
saleable basic replicable interventions
second and variably you need to engage
both the health sector and a non health
sector it may be the agronomists are
playing a role the nutritionists are
playing a major role the water managers
are playing a major role and so on third
is combining prevention and treatment
fourth is that households are the locus
of probably most of the health care
because mothers and you'd like to think
father's but I am going to say mothers I
take care of their children and need to
help to do so so they need to be
empowered to be able to do so you need
tricks of the trade so-called mass
application for instance vaccine days
all the children get vaccinated or every
household gets bad naps in a free
distribution and so forth and then
application of em help this is new
mobile health technologies the power of
the mobile phone or the other hand held
devices for public health will be
absolutely phenomenal tell me by the way
am I going ours who are you have another
tentative sign yet okay good because I
have a tendency to seek first semester
are waving me off when okay but just
just to make sure all right all right
fine so I there are many many kinds of
diseases that can be very quickly
control and typically are not simply
because the basic interventions are not
made available or people are not trained
in the very basic things that can be
done and I've shown in this graph some
of the so-called quick wins that have
been achieved for some of these
parasitic diseases like lymphatic
filariasis or elephantiasis which is a
mosquito transmitted disease trachoma
which causes blindness schistosomiasis
which is a worm infection all of these
have really powerful very low-cost
medicines or preventatives that can be
applied and people lived lives of misery
because they don't have access to very
basic things like in its active site
free defendant and yet with a little bit
of forethought and determination you can
sail up the access to these treatments
very rapidly and powerfully so what is
really happening in not it all aspects
in some cases is in social that certain
groups just are excluded in some cases
it has a lot to do with gender that
women and some societies just are not
thought about in terms of gaining access
to crucial Health Service needs but in
general at the setting that we're
working in throughout sub-saharan Africa
the problem is poverty and poverty means
that the most basic resources cannot be
brought to bear and that's true
incidentally whether you're thinking
about the household the community or the
national government a lot of times there
are protests against
national government why don't they do
something and so on now sometimes these
governments are quite miserable like
Mugabe for example but very often
they're just poor and there's no way to
mobilize the resources that are needed
at any level the household can't afford
it you say okay households Californa
we're going to give community insurance
that's kind of a World Bank idea but the
community is a group of poor people so
that doesn't change anything and then
you say okay let the national government
do with the national government taxes
poor people so they don't collect very
much in revenues and so there's no way
no matter how you allocate it you just
can't cover the basic health system and
this is a touch i gotta i have to update
this this is from a few years ago the
income expenditures of different levels
for health and in our country now you
know in 2009 the average level of health
spending will be eight thousand dollars
per person and in a typical sub-saharan
African country out of domestic revenues
who will be eight dollars per person one
thousand the rate but that's not because
they don't care that's because if you're
in an impoverished country eight dollars
maybe all the budget can afford and
that's why the development aid is so
important now aid is a very unpopular
idea and there's a new book also called
dead aid of a woman from Uganda educated
at Harvard claiming you know eight is
terrible it's degrading it's humiliating
it doesn't work it leads to corruption
and so on and so we should eliminate all
of it that's a death sentence she
doesn't have a clue
she doesn't have a clue and by the way
it's easy to go to Harvard and not have
a clue I know that you have to get out
into the villages and I think she didn't
get out of the villages she went out to
London and went to Goldman Sachs others
ass and so I don't like the loose talk
about this because we need the financing
for the vaccines for the bed nets for
the medicines and people that say they
don't do not have their children living
in these villages pure and simple so my
guess is what will you will you have
your own child even one night in a
village like this I'd be terrified in
the places were working because of one
macedo might can be devastated and so
people that have this claim oh it's not
the money of something else don't have
their children in the villages because
you know what it is the money it's only
rich people that say oh it's not the
money until their bank fails and they
sell us money that EBA and even the wall
street journal's all in favor of
bailouts now all of the Sun as long as
it for wall street so the least
developed countries send a few dollars
per capita and they get very little help
for it because they can't afford it this
is for again I apologize for not having
updated this but as of 2003 country lake
malawi could afford five dollars per
person per year at that time we were
spending in the public sector 2500 now
it's gone way up those are the health
disparities which come from mass income
disparities okay and the result is
disparities in the numbers of physicians
of course and now what the Commission
said was when we added it up this
for 1997 what the countries were
expected to be spending on their own and
this absolute minimum of what they would
need that was thirty four dollars in
2002 prices so you need right now my
guests about fifty dollars per person
per year for even the bare minimum that
now that sounds like a very small number
actually but you probably could get
rather far with fifty dollars per person
per year it's pretty tiny but it could
go a long way with immunizations in bed
nets and antibiotics and oral
rehydration and the lighting we are
approaching this problem in the
millennium villages so we're testing
this proposition we're always looking
for interns especially students from
Columbia University preference for for
Columbia but not exclusive I to work in
areas that are now in a dozen countries
and covering about half a million people
and we're seeing some wonderful results
at low cost of a systems approach this
is a map of where these villages are and
this is a community meeting with the
villagers to discuss various issues and
what we do is a holistic approach not
only in the health sector including
agriculture health education
infrastructure and business development
those are our five main points in the
health sector we're trying to roll out
new state-of-the-art low-cost scalable
approaches and everything in development
is alphabet soup so if you know what a
CT CHWs already teased IRS's and that
and those are you got it made all right
this would be multiple choice identify I
just as an example artemisinin
combination therapies the new generation
of an time
ariel's CHWs are the community health
workers who deliver them our VPS are the
new only to roughly two years old rapid
diagnostic tests with a drop of blood
you can say whether the fever is coming
from malaria as opposed to some other
pathogen that's brand new IRS's indoor
residual spraying of insecticide and and
so is the El Nino Southern Oscillation
that's the weather pattern that affects
the tropics which also determines
epidemic periods for malaria in some
regions next next okay I'm actually
going to stop here because you're you
can look at the rest of the slides I
made a series of recommendations a
couple of years ago about the global
sale approach how we could spend one
tenth of one percent of our income to
address these challenges but let me
summarize what good it's the main
message that I'm trying to convey when
we look at the situation the world we
find extraordinarily wide disparities
health which is why you're having your
pork congress those exist with these
societies and they also exist across
societies income exclusion and geography
are in my opinion the three major
determinants of these health disparities
you typically see them working together
we taken on the question of the worst of
the health disparities on the planet
which is the massive amount of suffering
and dying in the forest region of the
world
sub-saharan Africa they're certainly the
primary driver of disaster is the
extreme poverty but in shaped by the
physical environment by the tropical
ecology and also by cultural disparities
within communities especially gender
discrimination but also sometimes ethnic
exclusion as well once you identify the
core of where these disparities emerge
from both in their literal pathogenesis
what are the causes of disease in the
biological sense and then step back
understand the social context and then
step back one more time and asked what
can be done about them it turns out that
a lot to be done about this kind of
suffering everything that causes the
mask that malaria rested for infection
diarrheal disease unsafe childbirth
vaccine-preventable diseases elected
tropical diseases vitamin deficiencies
vellore and protein deficiencies that's
the range all of those have
scientifically proven interventions that
can be brought to bear now people don't
live in intervention space they live in
communities so whatever you do has to be
delivering communities there has to be a
real life wait to translate the theory
the potential money the more dental
instruments into real health delivery
and that involves not only a systematic
approach but it involves a tremendous
engagement with the communities as well
our hypothesis is that this can be
accomplished on the order of about fifty
dollars per person
per year and with that amount of money
it should be possible given the power of
our tools sound the new kinds of
medicines long-lasting anti-malaria
Venice these cell phones that can be
great for emergency reports for an hour
community health workers even for taking
pictures of seeing conditions and
emailing them back to a clinic for
advice many things that can be done now
that are extremely excited for training
people on the phones because now we're
dating I kind of love this part of it
because it's even happening in the
villages if we're getting wireless
broadband to greatly empower people who
just a few years ago were stuck in real
physical isolation and now they're not
stuck in that isolation that one can
design the responses I show you cases of
the quake disease decline we're seeing
Matty malaria we're seeing that in
unsafe childbirth or definitely seeing
that measles we're definitely seeing
that in be warming we're definitely
seeing that if some nutritional
improvement especially when the
community is able to grow more food
because of the interventions in the
agriculture side so well economics is
and everything money house and the money
can be made to work small amounts from
the rich world and translate it to
massive numbers
live safe since the sale of what's
needed is roughly comparable to the sale
of wall street bonuses and since we're
paying that money now I'm intent on
getting back those bonuses and redefine
the money
so we have about three minutes for
questions ideally you can come up to the
microphone but you can really really
providing donation which eventually
important
self-sufficiency what do you think are
these donations are you providing
they're wily just providing
great thank you so you know for the
health side of course there is training
and community empowerment and awareness
and actually we're trying in the village
where we're working to create a whole
patter of community health workers who
are young people from the villages
typically with a high school education
otherwise could it be employed with
their skills in the communities because
farming is is just about the only
activity so part of it is to create a
whole professional in large numbers of
young professionals in help even with
one year train not met not doctors and
nurses but outreach workers part of it
is training for economic
self-sufficiency we have a major
component of the millennium villages
project something that I strongly trying
to work on at the international level to
help peasant farmers be more productive
so that they can start earning their own
income that becomes saving improving
their farms buying more livestock
improving the quality of the livestock
starting small businesses getting into
agribusiness farmer cooperatives and so
on so there's an income generation
aspect to this idea which is crucial I
will be in favor of open-ended aid by
the way if it was for help if that was
what's needed but the idea really is the
estate from poverty it's not to just
help for people it's to help them escape
from poverty but to stay alive in the
interim during the period when they
can't help themselves and so I think one
needs to combine strong community
leadership training social service
and keep it out of the power it should
come as a package if so we'd like to
honor you we are just so impressed with
the fact that economists could turn his
brilliance toward the issues of solving
global poverty with the love of
dedication that you have towards so
we're presenting you with the Isaiah
award here in my sending for outstanding
service and seeking justice and
correcting oppression honoring Jeffrey D
sex PhD director of the Earth Institute
put a leg professor sustainable
development and professor of Health
Policy and management alum University
and special advisers the United Nations
Secretary General on the Monday of
development goals for providing
leadership in ending extreme global
poverty and ensuring environmental
sustainability mar 6
the preceding program was brought to you
by Teachers College Columbia University
please visit us online at iTunes TC
columbia edu